[Music]
Columbia has given me really an
opportunity to explore the diverse range
of disciplines that I've been trained in
but my affiliation with the Institute
has also then allowed me to explore the
history of african-american studies so I
consider myself also a cultural
historian I'm not an architectural
historian but a cultural historian who
really investigates race in the built
environment so on the sort of deep dive
scholarly archival work I'm writing a
book called building race and nation
looking at the influence of slavery and
Native American disposition on American
Civic architecture which basically goes
from the founding of the nation 1776 up
to the eve of the Civil War and I'm
looking at the the architecture of white
house and the Virginia State House as a
lens to understand how were white
founding fathers building these
institutions toward liberty and justice
that were going to be the sites of
governance and adjudication symbols of
all of these wonderful Enlightenment
values yet solely dependent on it slave
labor to build it and also run those
spaces and then these projects being
built on land dispossessed from Native
Americans and within that is a
formulation of racial identity linked to
national identity and so I think it can
be a rich study to sort of understand
all of those entanglements which are
clearly still operative today